>>> A YOG AMERICAN WHOSE NAME
IS TYLER JACOB NOW FREE FROM
RUSSIAN FORCES AFTER BEING
DETAINED AT A BORDER CHECK POINT
IN CRIMEA FOR TEN DAYS.
AT THE TIME HE DIDN'T KNOW WHY
HE WAS BEING DETAINED BUT SOON
LEARNED THAT HE WAS IMPRISONED
BECAUSE THEY THOUGHT HE MIGHT BE
A SPY.
AFTER HIS RELEASE TYLER TRAVELED
HOME FROM TURKEY TO MINNESOTA, A
TWO-DAY JOURNEY.
HIS MOM DIDN'T EVEN KNOW HE WAS
COMING HOME TODAY.
HERE IS THEIR SURPRISE REUNION
.
>> WHAT THE --!
TERRY!
>> WHAT?
>> COME HERE!
>> COMING.
>> COME HERE.
>> YEAH.
DUDE!
WHAT ARE YOU DOING HERE?
>> GOT SENT HOME.
>> OH, MY GOSH.
HAVEN'T EVEN STARTED THE
INTERVIEW YET.
TYLER JACOB AND HIS MOM TINA
HAUSER JOINS ME NOW.
LOOK AT YOU, TINA.
TYLER, WE WERE WORRIED SICK
ABOUT YOU.
TINA AND I HAVE BEEN ON
TELEVISION TALKING ABOUT YOU AND
WORRYING ABOUT YOU AND WE ARE SO
HAPPY YOU'RE HOME.
HOW YOU DOING?
>> EXHAUSTED.
LIKE IT'S BEEN A JOURNEY.
BUT, I MEAN, I GUESS I'M STILL
HERE, SO I HAVE A POSITIVE
ATTITUDE.
I'M GRATEFUL FOR EVERYBODY THAT
HELPED ME.
>> WHAT DID YOU THINK, TINA,
WHEN YOU OPENED THE DOOR?
YOU SAID WHAT THE -- BEEP?
>> I WAS TOTALLY SHOCKED.
I WAS NOT EXPECTING THIS AT ALL.
BETWEEN HIM, HIS WIFE, AND BETH,
YOUR PERSON THERE, AND HIS DAD
ARE ALL GOING TO GET A GOOD WORD
FROM ME.
THEY ALL WERE IN ON IT.
>> TINA, YOU WERE WORRIED SICK
HONESTLY.
HOW DO YOU FEEL?
>> I AM SO RELIEVED TO HAVE MY
SON SITTING NEXT TO ME.
THIS IS THE BEST DAY EVER.
IT'S LIKE HIM BEING BORN ALL
OVER AND BEING HOME IN MY ARMS
AGAIN.
IT'S PERFECT.
>> HAD YOU THOUGHT THE WORST?
I HATE TO ASK YOU THAT BUT I
KNOW MOMS ARE LIKE THAT.
>> I DID THINK THE WORST.
I WAS SO FEARFUL HE'D BE
TORTURED AND KILLED AND GET THE
NEWS THAT HE WAS SAFE AND WAS
GOING TO BE RELEASED WAS THE
BIGGEST JOY IN MY LIFE.
TO HAVE HIM SITTING NEXT TO ME
AND IN MY HOME WITH ME IS THE
BIGGEST CHRISTMAS PRESENT I
COULD EVER ASK FOR.
>> HE'S A GROWN MAN, BIG BOY,
BUT ALWAYS YOUR BABY, RIGHT?
>> THAT'S TRUE.
ALWAYS MY BABY.
>> TILE E. THIS IS SERIOUS
STUFF.
LET'S TALK ABOUT YOUR JOURNEY.
I MEAN, IT IS HARROWING.
YOU WERE DETAINED BY RUSSIAN
FORCES AT A CHECK POINT AND THEN
HELD FOR TEN DAYS.
SERIOUSLY WE WERE LOOKING AT THE
VIDEO THEY CAPTURED.
YOU IN A TRANSFER VAN OR
SOMETHING.
AND THEN AFTER THAT YOU JUST
KIND OF DISAPPEARED.
WE DIDN'T KNOW WHAT HAPPENED TO
YOU.
WHAT DID THEY TELL YOU, DID YOU
HAVE ANY IDEA WHAT WAS
HAPPENING?
>> TO BEGIN WITH, NO.
SO I WAS SITTING AT THE CHECK
POINT FOR I THINK IT WAS LIKE
SEVEN HOURS.
SEVEN OR EIGHT HOURS BEFORE THEY
FINALLY TOLD ME, HEY.
WE HAVE THIS PROTOCOL THAT YOU
HAVE TO SIGN.
THEY WERE TRYING TO FORCE ME
WITHOUT TELLING ME ANYTHING
ABOUT IT.
BY 6:00 IN THE MORNING SUNDAY
THEY SAID WE CAN TAKE YOU HERE
TO SLEEP AND LOCKED ME IN A
PRISON CELL AND THEN LATER IN
THE AFTERNOON THEY CAME AND
PICKED ME UP AND TOOK ME TO
COURT AND CHARGED ME WITH NOT
GIVING MY PASSPORT AND THEN
DETAINED ME FOR A TOTAL OF TEN
DAYS.
>> HOW DID THEY TREAT YOU IN
CUSTODY?
>> SO THE FIRST TWO DAYS WEREN'T
SO GREAT.
ONCE I GOT TO THE JAIL, THEY
WERE ABSOLUTELY PERFECT TO ME.
LIKE AS MUCH AS I'D LIKE TO SAY
RUSSIANS ARE BAD PEOPLE FOR
INVADING A SOVEREIGN COUNTRY
THAT THESE PEOPLE WERE SOME OF
THE NICEST PEOPLE I'VE MET.
I MEAN, THERE WAS THREE CAPTAINS
THAT ROTATED IN THE JAIL AND TWO
OF THEM WOULD SPEAK ENGLISH WITH
ME AND ONE OF THEM WOULD WINK AT
ME WHEN I'D GET PULLED TO GO GET
QUESTIONED AND HE WOULD LIKE
MAKE SURE HE KNEW THAT OR THAT I
KNEW THINGS WERE GOING WELL.
>> WERE THERE OTHER PEOPLE HELD
CAPTIVE OR DETAINED?
WERE THERE OTHER PEOPLE DETAINED
WITH YOU?
>> NO.
I WAS THE ONLY ONE DETAINED ON
THE BUS.
>> THERE WERE SIX BUSES?
>> THERE WERE SIX BUSES AND A
TOTAL OF I THINK 115 PEOPLE.
I WAS THE ONLY ONE DETAINED.
>> THEY THOUGHT YOU MIGHT BE A
SPY.
I MEAN, DID YOU HAVE TO PROVE TO
THEM THAT YOU WEREN'T?
>> YEAH.
THEY WENT THROUGH, THEY TOOK MY
LAP TOP, MY PHONE, AND MY
TABLET.
COPIED ALL THE HARD DRIVES AND
SIFTED THROUGH EVERYTHING THAT I
HAD.
THE RUSSIANS BELIEVE IN THIS
MYTH THAT 007, THE LEGEND, HIS
COVER STORY IS BEING AN ENGLISH
TEACHER SO THEY THOUGHT I WAS
LIKE THE LEGEND.
>> I HEAR THAT LAUGH TINA.
YOU CAN LAUGH NOW.
WOW.
YOUR MOM SAID SHE THOUGHT THE
WORST.
SHE THOUGHT THEY MIGHT TORTURE
YOU OR WERE YOU IN FEAR OF
ANYTHING LIKE THAT OF BEING HELD
FOR A LONG TIME AND WHAT THE
POSSIBLE CONSEQUENCES WERE?
>> SO THE BEGINNING PART OF IT,
YES.
I WAS A BIT CONCERNED.
BY WEDNESDAY, HE WAS STILL
QUESTIONING ME VERY HEAVILY
ABOUT BEING A SPY.
LIKE HOW DO YOU KNOW THIS PERSON
BECAUSE I HAD A RESUME FOR
SOMEBODY WHO HAD GOVERNMENT
BACKGROUND ON MY COMPUTER
BECAUSE I WAS STARTING A NEW
SCHOOL AND THEY WANTED ME TO USE
IT AS AN EXAMPLE.
I DIDN'T KNOW WHO THE PERSON WAS
AT ALL.
HE WAS CONSTANTLY TELLING ME,
HEY.
YOU KNOW THIS PERSON.
HIS NUMBER IS IN YOUR CONTACTS
IN YOUR PHONE.
I KEPT TELLING HIM IT WASN'T.
AND HE FINALLY THURSDAY COMES
BACK AND SAYS I WENT THROUGH ALL
OF YOUR CONTACTS.
THAT NUMBER ISN'T IN THERE.
AND YOU'RE JUST AN ENGLISH
TEACHER THAT'S IN A BAD
SITUATION.
>> I JUST WANT TO PLAY THIS FOR
YOU.
YOUR PARENTS WERE ON THE SHOW
WHEN THIS FIRST HAPPENED.
WATCH
>> I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE I
WANT TO SEE A VIDEO OF MY SON TO
MAKE SURE HE IS SAFE AND HEALTHY
AND THAT HE KNOWS THAT MOM IS
DOING HER BEST TO BRING HIM
HOME.
AND I MISS HIM AND I LOVE HIM.
>> MY GOSH.
YOU WEREN'T ABLE TO COMMUNICATE
WITH THEM.
DID YOU KNOW THEY WERE FIGHTING
FOR YOUR RELEASE?
>> I DIDN'T KNOW ANYTHING UNTIL
SATURDAY WHEN HE TOOK ME, LIKE
HE HAD TO TAKE ME OUT FOR TWO
HOURS, TOOK ME TO LUNCH, GAVE ME
A LATTE AND THEN SHOWED ME ON
HIS PHONE THE ARTICLE THAT WAS
PROCESSED WITH YOU GUYS THAT YOU
WERE ALL FIGHTING AND HAD AMY
KLOBUCHAR AND STUFF INVOLVED.
>> THEY WOULDN'T LET YOU REACH
OUT TO YOUR FAMILY?
OR CALL ANYBODY?
>> NO.
THEY WOULDN'T LET ME USE MY
PHONE BECAUSE THEY HAD IT IN
DETENTION SO I COULDN'T CONTACT
ANYBODY.
I JUST USED MY RESOURCES AND
TALKED TO THE PERSON IN MY CELL
WITH ME AND HAD THEM GET IN
CONTACT WITH MY WIFE THROUGH
INSTAGRAM.
I HAD ONE MESSAGE IN PER DAY AND
ONE MESSAGE OUT PER DAY.
>> YOU SEEM LIKE A VERY CALM AND
LEVEL HEADED YOUNG MAN.
I THINK YOU SAID THAT IT WAS
YOUR SIX YEARS IN THE MILITARY
THAT PREPARED YOU TO BE IN
PRISON BUT THE WORST PART WAS
BEING SEPARATED FROM YOUR WIFE
AND YOUR DAUGHTER.
SO TELL US PLEASE ABOUT BEING
REUNITED WITH THEM AS WELL.
>> IT WAS THE BEST DAY EVER ON
SATURDAY WHEN I GOT TO BE BACK
WITH THEM.
ME AND MY WIFE CAME OUT OF THE
CAFE WHERE WE WERE MEETING AND
ALMOST CAME RUNNING TO ME AND WE
HUGGED PROBABLY THREE TO FOUR
MINUTES STRAIGHT.
WHEN WE WALKED BACK IN THE
DAUGHTER GOT UP AND RAN OVER TO
ME AND I PICKED HER UP AND
CARRIED HER BACK TO THE TABLE
AND WE SPENT ALL DAY AT THE MALL
THERE AND THE DAUGHTER JUMPED ON
THE TRAMPOLINES.
IT WAS, WE DID GOOD FAMILY STUFF
TO BRING BACK TO EACH OTHER.
WE DEFINITELY MISSED EACH OTHER
A LOT.
>> WE SPENT A LOT OF TIME
TALKING ABOUT YOU, TYLER.
WE HAD A NUMBER OF INTERVIEWS
WITH YOUR MOM, WITH YOUR
PARENTS, WITH THE HELP OF THE
STATE DEPARTMENT, SENATOR
KLOBUCHAR WHO WAS ALSO ON THE
SHOW WITH YOUR PARENTS AND
FINALLY ABLE TO SECURE YOUR
RELEASE.
HOW DID YOU LEARN YOU WERE GOING
TO BE FREE?
>> SO I GUESS I KNEW FROM THE
BEGINNING THAT I WAS GOING TO BE
FREED ON THE 22nd AT 8:00
BECAUSE THAT IS WHAT MY
STIPULATIONS WERE.
BUT I AM ASSUMING THAT WITH ALL,
EVERYBODY, LIKE THE WORK THEY
WERE DOING IN CONTACTING THE
MOSCOW EMBASSY THAT THE KIND OF
PRESS ON THE PEOPLE QUESTIONING
ME, BASICALLY HEY.
HE IS JUST AN AMERICAN IN A BAD
SPOT TRYING TO FLEE THE COUNTRY.
I KNOW IT HELPED A LOT.
>> YOUR MOM IS SITTING RIGHT
NEXT TO YOU.
HE IS SITTING RIGHT NEXT TO YOU,
MOM.
WHAT DID YOU WANT TO SAY TO HIM?
>> I'M JUST GLAD HE IS HOME, SO
GLAD.
THAT HUG WAS THE BEST THING I
COULD HAVE EVER GOTTEN IN A LONG
TIME.
>> YEAH.
DEFINITELY.
>> YOU WORRIED YOUR MOM.
SHE WAS WORRIED SICK.
WHAT DO YOU WANT TO SAY TO HER?
>> DEFINITELY FEELS GOOD TO BE
BACK HOME BUT IT DOESN'T FEEL
LIKE HOME YET BECAUSE THE WIFE
AND DAUGHTER AREN'T HERE.
>> YEAH, WELL, WE CAN'T WAIT FOR
YOU TO BE REUNITED WITH THEM.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WE'RE GLAD YOU'RE OKAY.
TINA, GET SOME SLEEP.
TYLER, GET SOME SLEEP.
YOU SAID YOU'VE BEEN UP FOR 25
HOURS NOW.
>> YES.
GOOD LUCK.
WE'LL LET YOU GO A